[Música]
la pandemia canceló eventos nos confió
en casa y por eso hoy nos rendimos ante
venecia el primer festival de cine en
llevarse a cabo presencial demostrando
con éxito que el arte puede seguir si se
siguen las reglas y no han sido pocas
todos los presentes tuvieron que hacerse
la prueba para entrar al palazzo del
cinema no hubo pases sin reserva online
louis a la que no se cumplieran las
distancias mientras que un muro protegió
la alfombra roja del lido muy a pesar de
fans y cinéfilos que ha supuesto menos
cintas menos secciones un ambiente más
sombrío y silencioso pero la osadía el
atreverse a reiniciar el cine y
preservar su experiencia ha hecho ganar
a la muestra valiosos méritos la imagen
de varios directores de festivales entre
ellos ya gifs temáticas pasará a la
historia como muestra de solidaridad eso
en una inauguración que por primera vez
en 11 años fue a cargo de un filme
italiano
el drama blach y sobre los
resentimientos que genera un matrimonio
si se enamoran cambiar sin dijo la
visita tus elvin hábitos y se enamoraron
que la abrirá el telón se debe a la
ausencia de hollywood y sin hollywood
que ha triunfado todo lo demás la
variedad de géneros el cine de autor y
sobre todo ellas se intuía cualquier
planchett como líder del jurado
principal también con la entrega de dos
león de oro a la trayectoria de la
actriz filas gol fácil y la cineasta al
wii pero se confirmó con la presencia de
ocho directores entre las 18 películas
en competencia en ellas las mujeres por
igual protagonista desde el rol de
francis mcdormand en nom atlán una
anómala que en caravana busca descubrir
los márgenes de eeuu hasta de war to com
un western sin fallos la historia de
amor de dos lesbianas en 1856 la actriz
vanesa kirby juntos y álamo repite en la
unwra pixies of woman para parir a un
hijo que no será destrozando a la pareja
mientras que romo la gran rompe las
biografías en mí
como el honor hija de carl marx nos
llevará por su activismo social
destapando a la vez sus incongruencias
sobre la idea de protesta y patriarcado
berlín
[Música]
y zaida y la russa de conrad no suena
punk pero sus luchas tampoco han acabado
la primera jasmila zbanic trata por
quinta vez el centro de su obra la
masacre de strobe nitza contada a través
de una traductora de la onu una
violencia que con peso narra andréi
konchalovski en otra masacre la de nuevo
checas perpetrada por la cajeme tal vez
más dura porque somos julia una
funcionaria fiera al partido nostálgica
de stalin contraria a la huelga pero
cuya vida cambia cuando desaparece su
hija
[Música]
en esta extraña edición del festival más
antiguo del mundo solo una película
latinoamericana se coloca en la
selección la distopía nuevo orden del
mexicano michel franco
si bien no faltaron ni espías japoneses
con secretos que pueden cambiar una
guerra y el retrato del fracaso con un
joven obsesionado con la música
tradicional india en una cinta
apadrinada por alfonso cuarón y una
realidad tan universal como los niños
que malviven vendiendo en la calle para
sun children el iraní majid majidi
entrevistó a 4000 menores sólo cinco de
152 millones en el mundo protagonizan
esta historia con un tesoro escondido en
un colegio
pero ahora es un decir
tiene
a mi madre es de esos
un alma
hay muchas y bbva
dijo que ahora ambos han estado
la cosecha de esta muestra era para
celebrar la venecia no podía dejar caer
a documentales como un nocturno una
observación sobre el medio oriente o el
amor el amor que representa el filme
palestino gaza' mon amour' sobre un
pescador que quiere casarse a los 60 a
veces no sale bien y pedro almodóvar nos
lo recuerda en una versión libre de la
obra la voz humana su primer corto en
inglés con un desamor un dolor que no
pierde entereza en tilda swinton y al
que seguirán próximamente dos cortos más
[Música]
pronto también sabremos más de one night
in miami el estreno de regina king como
directora del dif
con jim broadbent helen mirren
encarnando la esposa y el propio kempton
bunton un taxista que robó el retrato de
goya de la galería nacional de londres
con el fin de aumentar el cuidado a los
mayores
nuestra guinda el punto final de este
viaje por venecia es una mosca la mosca
de mandíbula absurda cinta de francés
que en tan yukio con dos dispersos
amigos y anv el ex arco polos
liberándose al fin en la comedia
cuídense y muchas gracias
o no
2 a 1
así